Oh
blacks in uniform
I
oh man
come on yo we are soldiers in the army
so if you could just do me a quick favor
and I'm not telling you I'm not asking
you but I'm allowing you for folks who
want to go back out leaves and engage
our young boys I say we do it instant is
no run run it's no looking down it's no
talking about it's no saying you did
this right or wrong it's just engaging
our young brothers all right for love
cuz that's what they need I got going to
scream in the crossfire
birdneck oh yeah Oh Burnett come on you
bitch your bro we're shown something
different show the world sup that's
right hey wait you gotta activo tonight
yep not populate into we weren't stop
populate to jail listen please don't die
pigeon how can surf ready right now look
at them say my God my God if they only
knew tonight we convene both the Bloods
and the Crips and the 39th we the
collective group of ministers of
Baltimore met here with more than 200
strong we were aiding the police let's
make this clear it's 200 strong aided
the police tonight as we were able to
remove a brigade of police forward while
we were able to put out two fires
Oh